con esta vista de la costa taiwanesa los
aviones de combate chinos surcan los
aires continuando con los ejercicios
militares ordenados por beijing en medio
de tensiones latentes con la isla
mientras tanto china también ha
intensificado su disputa diplomática con
eeuu deteniendo el diálogo con
washington sobre una serie de temas
incluida la defensa la lucha contra las
drogas y el cambio climático al visitar
filipinas el sábado el secretario de
estado de eeuu anthony blinken calificó
la decisión de irresponsable han cerrado
ocho áreas diferentes en las que
nuestros dos países han podido trabajar
juntos el mayor emisor de carbono del
negro ahora se niega a participar en el
combate contra la crisis climática es
suspender la cooperación climática no
castiga a eeuu castiga al mundo en
particular al mundo en desarrollo
el sábado marcó el tercer día de los
ejercicios militares más grandes de
china en taiwán
según la agencia estatal de noticias
xinhua beijing ha movilizado más de 100
aviones y más de 10 buques de guerra el
ministerio de defensa de taiwán dijo que
los ejercicios del sábado eran una
práctica potencial para un ataque a la
isla
se detectaron múltiples naves del
ejército popular de liberación alrededor
del estrecho de taiwán algunas han
cruzado la línea media en un posible
ataque simulado las medidas se producen
luego de la visita de la presidenta de
la cámara de representantes de eeuu
nancy pelosi a taiwán a principios de
esta semana pelosi es la política
estadounidense de más alto rango en 25
años en visitar la isla que beijing
considera su territorio